it's time to babble the [ __ ] on from the
Eldorado hotel and casino in Reno Nevada
it's the 100th episode of Hollywood
babble-on with your host Kevin Smith
[Music]
how nice you guys are [ __ ] sweet did
my mother call in advance or something
treat him nice tonight because it's a
[ __ ] anniversary of sorts ladies and
gentlemen
it is Saturday night and Reno Nevada
so let's babble the [ __ ] on for the
100th time man I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman thank you for being
here tonight Reno as Kevin mentioned is
our 100th episode of Hollywood babble-on
little did we know a couple years ago
we'd be doing this for a hundred [ __ ]
times I know there are very few things
I've ever done for a hundred times it's
masturbation and this it's a it's a
milestone man it's and it's been a
delight to sit beside you for all this
time you make me laugh it's I get to
listen to those impressions over and
over again has been a blast and look it
brought us to Reno together biggest
little town in the world right here it's
what this is what does that mean exactly
biggest little city in the world I
haven't figured what its crowning
scrotums biggest scrotums well now that
I'm in town has the biggest scrotum yes
[Applause]
they are huge so you've heard and the
legend I've heard man I remember was
passed down from generation to
generation sure my grandfather sang it
to me when I was a boy it's like big
balls big balls they called him the man
with big balls gar man was the man with
big balls there is a second verse even
more meaningful Oh God how dare you sir
well you're witnessing the final episode
of Hollywood babble-on this evening
let's get to it you know it is our
hundredth episode that we're celebrating
tonight and just well wishes galore from
everyone who listens thanks so much for
all the emails and the tweets also
celebrities have been contacting us
letting us know how happy they are to
celebrate our hundredth episode when he
says Liberty's you mean like Jason Mewes
yeah professor Stephen Hawking [ __ ]
that really smartest man in the world
he sent a little audio message to me
today at least I think it was him so I
brought it along to play for everyone
and here's professor Stephen Hawking
congratulating Kevin and myself on our
100th episode was that it he included a
score he's the smartest man in the world
he's gonna produce it what an arrogant
prick
he knows how time works in [ __ ] cut him
a break it's actually not a bad idea to
carry your own score around man
see so when you're saying [ __ ] you're
just like I really mean it you could
play like [ __ ] Batman music or when
you're into the wife you know like I
want to give you a back rub
1:06 you but just but no lyrics just the
bullying of the musical version
good evening Ralph and Kevin I have been
enjoying your podcasts after long days
of solving the secrets of the universe I
wanted to make sure you have a shout out
from the under 100 podcast
congratulations
although I have a good sense of humor I
have to say your impression of me
performing creepy clown sucks a bank of
hairy balls better even if my caretakers
build my feeling tube with the fifth of
Jack but in all seriousness thank you
both for all the funny keep up the good
work and give that penis a sandwich and
he brought back bring gift that penises
ham was only appropriate yeah he's the
one guy that really makes you feel
unaccomplished yes of course I can walk
so I got that going for me well I can
I'm just saying
accomplished a lot can walk to the
fridge the worm turns at a hundred for
you after a hundred episodes you like
here's who I really am yeah and who I
really am is I'm proud not to be
crippled I'm not proud not to be
crippled doesn't it be proud about
I'm just glad not to be it's a subtle
difference uh ttle difference I just
appreciate moving every episode for a
hundred episodes in a row we like to
give particular shoutouts to people
who've come long distances or
celebrating special occasions tonight is
no different
let's kick it off with the shoutouts
let's shout out Kevin and brown sir get
your [ __ ] out
[Music]
did you cop creepy clowns on
no wires no Anglet Mike I was getting
ready to swing it it would have hit
somebody in the [ __ ] face man
babble off we're [ __ ] sued I do also
want to give it a heads up that kevin is
working all the audio cubes this evening
yeah yeah when we're on the road this is
my little job and problem is I always
forget and smoke a lot of weed so my
little job is a bit more complex Ralph
has to point a lot our first shot at our
Trish and Tim here Trish hackler Trish
writes my name is Trish it's a good
start I will be attending the show with
my brother Tim my brother's girlfriend
Vicky couldn't make it tonight but she's
being daunted by neuroanatomy midterms
next week how dare you
Vicky's a lot [ __ ] smarter than you
sir I'll tell you that much
she's taking my neuroanatomy and you're
taking bong rips but to be fair he said
what we were all thinking she had to
make the difficult decision not to
attend tonight so if possible could you
guys shout out to her and lament her not
attending maybe Ralph could do it in his
Frank dr. Franken further impression it
would take a bit of the sting out of not
being up attend with us tonight thanks
to Trish heckler and Tim hello Vicki
we're so bummed out but you can't be
here tonight
I'm just the sweet transvestite
transsexual Reno Nevada if you are
anywhere near the lobby restrooms men's
side you're in a stall and you see a
foot tapping and you hear that voice
Ralph Garman likes to go glory holing on
the road stop it you know it's our
Halloween shows coming up maybe I'll
dress is frankenburger this year would
you like to see me in fishnets and a
bustier I would I would like to see that
I'll come in costume I will be gue
Silent Bob okay
our Dan and his lovely wife Carissa here
tonight Domanick charissa hi guys
dan writes my lovely wife Carissa and I
will be coming to your show on Saturday
it's weird to call her wife because
we're not married at the time I'm
writing this it's a message from the
past
but we will be getting married the day
before your show are you guys married
now you're married congratulations and
we hope that you're showing us a ring
either that or is like it's like so
hostile ma'am I was about to wish you a
happy win we were spending our honeymoon
with you guys oh man Dan right side
offer prima nocta but I'll probably have
beaten you to it I certainly hope so
oh the huh picking off or prima nocta
let's sexy that [ __ ] up
that's enough of that did you beat us to
it already so far so good for us are you
I don't understand
since we're newlyweds I was wondering if
Adam West might have any advice on how
to keep things perfect keep things
perfect in a marriage so cute the
newlyweds greetings citizens welcome to
the wonderful world of marriage I was
saying to my wife Burt Ward just the
other day
Burt either the dogs go or huge-o he's
gone now
just me and Alfred waxing the bat-poles
quickly old chum to my anus there you go
[Applause]
as Allison Hughes here with her friend
Steve hi guys this is the most
disturbing email I've ever gotten I
thought oh you know it'll make that
better on hold in case [ __ ] gets dark
shits gonna get dark trust me it doesn't
really yeah well then Color Me badd
Allison writes my boyfriend of 14 years
Steve and I will be coming to see you
guys we are from the heyo California am
I saying that correctly
Vallejo Vallejo Jesus Christ [ __ ] are
serious about your elves here aren't you
famous for being the suspect at home of
the Zodiac killer and the first US city
to go bankrupt well congratulations I
can see why you're so proud of the name
of the city get it right man it's
synonymous with pride and murder in
bankruptcy anyway I'm a huge fan but
Steve has never heard more than a minute
or two of the podcast because he is a
selfish dick
14 years Steve has put up with this 14
years I just left a similar conversation
at home man I bought tickets for the
show in the hopes that he'll develop a
sense of humor and we'll finally have
more in common than just our love of
weed we probably should have ended it
long ago but we forgot Jesus Christ
that's the that's the beauty of being a
stoner man that's the secret that you
drinkers don't understand because you
drinkers wake up you're like what the
[ __ ] happened stoners never wake up man
so they just live on a dream since he's
never seen the show Ralph would you as
David Lynch tell him a little of a
little bit about it he won't know who
David Lynch is but he won't get any
other nice references either so he might
as well keep it consistent
you see newlyweds 14 years that's what
14 years does they're all joking aside
not joking he's a sport for coming with
me and I'm lucky to have him Allison
well you guys seem very much in love and
you're creeping me the [ __ ] out hello
Steve David Lynch here welcome to the
show I understand you don't know much
about it it's mostly anal jokes with a
few [ __ ] thrown in it's not as bad as
it sounds not as funny as it sounds
either good luck to you Steve run Steve
Roddy
there you go there's a little David
Lynch from Twin Peaks
unfortunately [ __ ] all over marriage so
I want to give him a little bit of hope
to leave the show with man if the show
goes really well tonight since you
brought him and whatnot he would sport
for coming you got to let him sport [ __ ]
you do you know what sport [ __ ] is
how the hell we gonna get clearance for
that song do you want me to rewind any
other jokes tonight bitter Jeff Jones
and his wife Kirsten are you guys here
tonight how you doing guys Kirsten's
like oh we are coming to the show on the
6:00 for our 11th wedding anniversary
oh wow our core audience is just people
about to get married or people have been
married over a decade yeah people hate
each other I've been together for 14
years for people with faith or the 11
year people how do you feel how do you
feel the love of your people you okay
it's all good my wife's a big Muppets
fan can Kermit the Frog wish her a happy
anniversary
please tell her she's an awesome wife an
amazing mom and the greatest best friend
I could ask for
thank you Jeff Jones the Frog here and
apparently Jeff thinks you're pretty
good mm-hmm and he thinks you are you're
good mom you know in a good way
mm-hmm yeah and best friend
[Music]
I'm happy to see you know a couple
together for 11 years in frog ears it's
like that's death we don't last that
long
shut up and eat the [ __ ] frog and I am
here too it's just a thin line between
Piggy and Yoda
it's like bugging the taint are James
and Meredith here James and Meredith
okay you can sit down thank you so much
we got up that was cute not The Price is
Right my name is Meredith we'll be
attending the show with my boyfriend
James traveling from Northern California
to pop our Babylon cherries we have met
Kevin numerous times we even slept in
our car overnight to be first in line
for a Los Angeles DVD signing Kevin's
everywhere all the time you don't need
to sleep in your car if you just come to
my house next time yeah Ralph I would
love it if you can ask James in your Al
Pacino voice to take me to the bunny
ranch this weekend because I've always
wanted to see it and possibly for some
three-way action with a hooker we are
running the gamut of relationship is
that possible where is that place
Trump's right from how far from here
40 minutes from here 40 minutes from
legal [ __ ] a half hour half hour she
says this cuz like i know i worked there
it's a half hour when traffic's Lynam
and working like 30 minutes I read an
article about one brothel that brought
in a guy what is it
the Mustang Ranch does that they brought
in a guy
oh you from the Mustang Ranch we have a
bunch of [ __ ] in the audience
and to onstage I don't think I've ever
been propositioned so publicly before a
man not a [ __ ] you're a cashier
so you're the last yours is the last
face I see before I see someone who's
gonna [ __ ] me you're the person that's
like paper or plastic
she runs your [ __ ] and balls across the
scanner this is hot I want to be
involved funny you should say that
because the the shout out continues it
would be even better if Kevin made dick
sucking noises in the background we call
[Music]
James come on man you got the best
girlfriend in the world she wants to
take you to get some strange don't like
Yoda again you take that girlfriend of
yours to the Mustang Ranch have her give
you a discount Raul I know the cashier
there come on now with the cashier good
Kevin you ever had a prostitute have I
ever had a proverb in with a prostitute
yes I forgot we were doing a show
retail easy a couple times yeah it's fun
well one one time I got crabs so that
wasn't fun but mine was a threeway type
situation with a girl
hooker was a guy hey you know what time
it is what it's you made everyone sad
don't blame me blame captain fantastic
those you're new to the show the creepy
clown that came about because I would do
something that would creep Kevin out I
would do a deranged homicidal clown
putting on his white face makeup while
slowly singing the clown song that would
make that [ __ ] intent gaze man just
like wakes me up in the middle of the
night it's so horrifying so what we
started doing was doing wacky voices
singing that song putting the makeup on
to make it a little bit more fun and
palatable for Kevin this being our
hundredth episode we have a hidden house
request from will and Trish are willing
Trish here brother and sister will and
Trish hi guys
will and Trish right we'll be here at
your show on Saturday nights he
introduced me to HBO about a year ago I
will forever be grateful to him for that
to celebrate your 100th episode could
you flip things around and please have
Kevin do the creepy clown as bane from
The Dark Knight it is a special night it
is a special episode usually I do the
creepy clown but it does seem
appropriate it since we have a request
for it to flip things around you do the
creepy clown to me and they would like
you to do it in your legendary
impression of Bane from The Dark Knight
I haven't done it in like weeks so I'm
not sure if it hold on let me get the
boys let me get the boys well Bob's is
wondering why you would shoot too bad
okay
do-do-do-do-do-do-do ashes
do-do-do-do-do-do-do shoot a man do deep
now you make it now phone into your
vampire version I can't look at you man
all them do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
what a lovely singing voice hey go Willa
Trish what a special special night it is
you see something will never be seen
again
never wow man I almost broke a sweat on
that when I was scared we also get
emails from all around the world we read
them out loud here on the show in a
segment we like to call emails
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reaction
Susan Kemet from Rochester New York
writes I was recently cast in a local
theater production of The Sound of Music
this is the first role I've had onstage
in a musical since my senior year of
high school and I'm 48
do the math wait let Kevin do the math
I'll wait I was just doing the math
thirty-five years senior year of high
school should have been 18 okay all
right cut it either 30 or 30 many
choices with this be ready here 31 years
31 okay yeah since I'm playing a nun and
singing in an old church school Church
in Latin I have to admit I'm a little
flustered I was hoping that mate lead
that maybe Dudley Moore singing his
version of Edelweiss would calm my
nerves
thanks Susan Gemma Doug Lee Maura's
Arthur singing Adel vice for Susan
Gehman in Rochester New York flower
preaching you will not be surprising if
a flower came here Sarah flowers
marigold miss rose flowers are talking I
[Music]
was just kind of back out of me
where was I so then white soft and wise
I can't stop thinking about soft and
white things I'm so drunk
you look happy to meet me is that in
it's at the end a lot of people sent
this email after I talked about the sex
move called by Ralph Garman we talked
about that yeah my patented sex move
that I would like to have named after me
we talked about this one of the episodes
was to have a woman sitting on my face
pouring Jack Daniels over her body from
her breast down to her vagina while I
laughed at it and got the best the best
of both worlds in essence it to great
tastes that taste great together ton of
people emailed in this story about a
German company who this week announced a
new line of liqueur called G spirits
that before it's been bottled has been
poured over the naked breasts of
beautiful models I want some [ __ ]
residual money for this idea
they've got Playboy Playmates apparently
who poured the booze over their breasts
and then they catch it and then they put
it in a bottle look I got tits so I want
in on this I'll let him pour booze all
over my titties and you can roll into a
bottle and [ __ ] and you'll have little
pieces of hair [ __ ] you am I'm an Oreo
crumbs just kinds of things I'll charge
him way less 50 bucks the way you sweaty
it'll be like cutting [ __ ] liquor
with saline man this next email is from
Pam hi Ralph and Kevin my daughter is in
the Peace Corps in Moldova it sounds
made-up that sounds like oh I have a
girlfriend she lives in Canada Moldova
it's not where dr. doom oh my god she's
working to stop dr. doom I recently
discovered that many of the volunteers
there follow you guys religiously and
were shocked and my daughter a little
embarrassed that her mother was a
devoted fan could you please give a
shout-out to Holly Jen and all those
other hard-working Peace Corps
volunteers across the globe who lock
into you for the funny when they are so
far from home and have limited resources
for entertainment
[ __ ] that it's great hope they are
listening and not just lying Oh [ __ ]
Peace Corps people are a bunch of liars
I'm writing this from the safety of my
parents home I'm sure the great
humanitarian Bill Cosby would love to
raise my daughter's spirits raising up
got a tree that has a lot of mold now
turn it off
you are in the free squad that leaves
you sit back and give the beverage
children some jell-o pudding pops thank
you
and lastly from Hamilton Ontario Canada
my husband Zack and I are huge fans of
yours right Sarah we regularly listen to
HBO together in August I surprised him
with tickets to your Ottawa show and I
have another surprise for him I recently
found out that I'm pregnant with our
first child and I can think of no better
way to tell Zach then through your
podcast really really Sarah you can
think of no better way what's his name
Zach Zach your ladies [ __ ] up and
pregnant could David Bowie please
announce to Zach the pregnancy through
song love you guys Sara so she would
like David Bowie to break the news to
Zach that he's going to be a father
you're going to be a dad
you're going to be a dancer you're going
to be a father
Sarah is Oh locked up Sarah's going to
have
[Music]
you're going to be a downside gonna be
changing shitty diaper
I wake up
[Music]
congratulations to you
[Music]
I hope that your father
[Laughter]
Oh your timing was impeccable that's a
hundred episodes worth of perfection
right there man
thank you so much every week we also
have to say goodbye to some people in
show business who have had wonderful
careers they have passed us they've
passed us at all they passed on and we'd
like to give them a proper send-off in
the segment Tinseltown stiffs and now
another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed they will be missed
indeed this week it's our be grieves as
his name he was a pop singer in the late
60s early 70s for one of my favorite
one-hit wonders of all time a song
called take a letter Maria and if you
guys remember that song let's play a
little taste of that for people so they
can get a refresher in what that song
[Music]
that song went to number 2 in the
Billboard charts what is that song about
it is the song of a man who goes home to
find his woman in the arms of another
man he has been working hard at the
office and she's been [ __ ] around on
him so he immediately leaves and goes
back to the office which relieves the
source of all his problems anyway tells
the secretary take a letter Maria and he
writes a letter saying to his wife he's
not coming home and he is going to
divorce her he's going to leave her and
then about three minutes later in the
song he realizes that he's in love with
his secretary and he asks her out that's
what that songs about a wonderful story
about a man who's obviously cannot be
alone I always assumed it was a song
about Latin teenage kids and love I have
no idea it's a song about a dude who
walks in sees another dude in his wife's
[ __ ] yes and then he goes back to work
immediately goes to his office to draft
a strongly worded letter about it that's
it and that was number two on the
chinami issue on the chart what would
you do you come home you see someone in
flagrante delicto with your wife yes do
you go to the office write a letter I
send an email now you know we've moved
on we've moved on this day and age I'd
probably eat about it and 140 characters
get your [ __ ] out of my wife's [ __ ] and
everybody hashtag I'm heartbroken but
take a tweet Maria really doesn't have
the same one song though that was his
only big hit a little bucket a little
like a big gulp of win [ __ ] all you
need every week we also like to talk
about celebrities are able to get out of
the way of their own egos and to help us
the regular folks in a segment we call
the Hollywood helpers
oh come on now got involved with myself
but I forgot I got to do the qz well
keeps you jumping this comes from Marty
Griffin a few years ago my wife Meg was
pregnant with our first child and she
was an extra on the set of a wonderfully
terrible movie called Public Enemies she
was in the middle of a long shoot with
no brakes no food and wasn't feeling
well she's pregnant keep in mind doubled
over and ready to puke she heard someone
ask her if she was okay without looking
up to see who it was and she explained
that she was three months pregnant
needed to eat when the kind voice
returned with an entire pizza from the
craft service table she looked up and
saw none other than dr. Manhattan
himself Billy Crudup ah she was shocked
and beyond thankful and I for one think
he deserves some recognition so four
years later he decided as ascendency
yeah that's nice of Billy Crudup to do
he's probably trying to [ __ ] her yeah it
almost makes up for him leaving his
pregnant girlfriend for another woman oh
my god that's right he did that I was
only kidding but you're right he's a guy
an utter cab duty lead which is like I
mean god bless him but you gotta have
your head examined you ever watch weed
yeah I was sitting next to my wife
watching that show I was like [ __ ] you I
started talking to [ __ ] out of it right
in front of Rose she was like I can't
help it look at that
she's amazing looking middle-aged woman
and talented and funny and cute and all
that stuff whatever but and he leave her
for he left her there Claire Danes yeah
she was pregnant at the time with Billy
Crudup skid and then he met Claire Danes
in some picture and then he left her
while she was still and he said take a
letter Claire day every week we take a
look at all the latest and greatest news
in show business with a segment we call
the HBO headlines
[Music]
this week we start with my favorite
story of the week Justin Bieber was in
Glendale Arizona this week he got out
there on stage and stopped singing
because he was busy vomiting that's
right
he grabbed his knees held his stomach
and proceeded to projectile vomit all
over the stage in Glendale Arizona best
part of the story the track he was
singing to kept singing so he still
heard his voice while he was vomiting he
was lip-syncing at the time he
immediately left the stage returned a
while later and then asked his fans will
you still love me even though I'm
throwing up on stage the audience
answered I take not one of the fans he
was addressing sir Bieber later tweeted
milk was a bad choice ha ha ha ha
from anchorman at the anchorman line
yeah no rumors man when I was a kid if a
[ __ ] rock star would have thrown up
on stage immediately people would have
been like you know why that happened he
sucked off a hundred [ __ ] and they
would always talk about like you know
about Rod Stewart right I'm like no what
about Rod Stewart they're like one night
Rod Stewart sucked so many dicks he had
to go to the emergency room that a pump
is [ __ ] its stomach a baby fell out man
I don't think a baby fell I don't think
that was the story was the story I think
a gerbil came out it was the story I
heard but that's not that instead like
people let him get away with people I
saw the footage man it's pretty hairy
everyone knows Bieber spits he doesn't
swallow that's why they know he's a well
known spitter what do you think made a
puke what do you think he says it was
nerves yeah but what do you think
conspiracy theory I think was his own
music I think the monitors were playing
baby baby baby he hurt himself and he
said I suck hey you pick the one song
that I could get behind though I like
that oh stop it
the Governator Arnold Schwarzenegger is
still out there pimping his new book
Total Recall see is his autobiographies
called Total Recall should be called
True Lies but it's called Total Recall
he's doing a ton of interviews to sell
this piece of [ __ ] and one of them this
week talked about how the stories in the
book as well how he almost ruined his
most famous catchphrase of course in the
Terminator film he says I'll be back and
that's the the the phrase that put him
on the on the on the map basically he
almost [ __ ] it up and here's Arnold
telling why what it was I could not
pronounce really well this Iowa so I
just contained the Jim can maybe just
say I will be back as it sounds more
like a machine I will be back this is no
no no this is look I don't tell you how
to act don't tell me how to write I
wrote the line I'll be back James
Cameron had to be thinking if we start
changing the [ __ ] script because of
words you can't pronounce we'll be here
all [ __ ] night no I can't say I'll I
can say owl can I say hello I'll just
[ __ ] say the line we'll fix it in
post well get Kevin Klein to come in and
recut it don't worry about it you've got
like a zone that books full of [ __ ]
stories we've heard other stories about
a man that's what you're going out to
sell the world a book with you like you
know one time I almost did a different
line in the movie if I was the
journalist I've been like did you [ __ ]
your maid for reals that don't you want
to hear more about me and Jim cab no no
no no no did you put your dick and Alice
the maid mr. Brady doesn't do that no
but one time I was like oh I don't like
those sunglasses almost didn't wear the
sunglasses ha ha ha Red Sonja what was
that like I [ __ ] you're not in the book
that I read this morning an excerpt it
said that he didn't talk to the press
after the story broke about him having
sex and impregnate his maid because he
wanted to retain his family's privacy he
wrote that in a book that he wrote where
he talks about his family
while we're talking about celebrities
and politics crossing paths Snoop Dogg
this week released
I'm sorry Snoop lion of course how how
silly of me to call him by the name
we've all been calling him for the past
30 years snoop lion released a list of
while he is pro Barack Obama and anti
Mitt Romney in this upcoming
presidential election he put on on the
Instagram thank you so much sir
instagrams I just wanted that [ __ ]
dudes trying to replace me isn't he back
the [ __ ] off kid I put in my time all
right you know how many [ __ ] times I
had to listen to Al Pacino say something
hey hey get your own [ __ ] guy some
new blood somebody's not tired of Al
Pacino perhaps I'm not tired of him oh
uh hey we put it on Instagram here's
just a couple of the ten on each side
that snoop gives the first number two on
the list of why he is voting for Obama
he mad Coolio number four he wears a
do-rag like me ooh
number five on the pro Obama list
Michelle got a fat ass no on the Mitt
Romney's side the reason he's not voting
for mitt number two on that list this
[ __ ] name is MIT you know he
brings up an excellent point that I
never saw covered on CNN that's number
three on that list [ __ ] got a dancing
horse
does he yeah his horse was in the
Olympics in in the dancing horse
competition massage sir not right now
I'm fine thank you John Travolta it's so
weird
why don't you besides me what you know
my [ __ ]
what's a compass dressage is the sport
that's the dancing horse sport we do the
ghost version quickly number four on the
anti mitt list he's a Mormon but he
ain't got no hose
I think Snoop thinks that if you're
Mormon you get multiple women like that
dude on The Learning Channel
Oh sister wives yeah no hos number ten
on the list this [ __ ] name is
the middle sadly this week amanda Bynes
was missing in action I was kind of sad
I was hoping to bring you some Amanda
Bynes story but she hasn't locked
herself in anything all week in her
absence though Lindsay Lohan has stepped
up her game
[Applause]
why don't you come to your senses Oh
Lindsay this week was assaulted in the
New York City hotel room when she
brought a bunch of people back from a
nightclub at 4:30 in the morning it's
not a good idea
hey all you drunks come back to my hotel
suite
who's got the blow she met a guy named
Christian LaBella who apparently was
taking photographs and videos with his
cell phone of Lindsay partying she won
at those pictures deleted they started
to tussle over the phone he threw her
down on the bed leaving scratches on her
hands Lindsay ran out of the room and
when she returned this guy choked her
out apparently threw her to the ground
and climbed on top of her the [ __ ] out
of here really friends had to pull the
man off of Lindsay according to witness
who's this man he's a guy who works for
a senator believe Republican or Democrat
I believe it's a Republican who they
both filed harassment charges against
each other no word on what legal
ramifications or whether she ever got
the phone or whether we'll ever see
those photos so he was hanging out with
them and probably taking [ __ ] on the
slide pics you bring strangers back to
your hotel room at 4:30 in the morning
everybody's loaded you've run the risk
of someone snapping a photo of you doing
I don't know a kilo will blow off some
guy's [ __ ] Michael Owen said he had not
spoken to his daughter Lindsay about
this or anything in years but as for
LaBella he said wait till I get this guy
Michael please
you don't tell everybody you're gonna
kill the guy before you kill him idiot
you just I don't want to bring the show
to a serious [ __ ] place but [ __ ] that
guy little girl from [ __ ] The Parent
Trap for Christ's sakes
this is Herbie the lovebug friends yes
yeah that'd be even scarier man pitcher
of fluid or a car of sentient car that's
like Christine but Christine's scary
little brother or something like that
the car would be weirdest weirder than a
giant pitcher of fluid coming through
the wall lease the car you've seen
before you've never seen a 12-foot tall
glass pitcher of red fluid coming at you
well maybe you have a drought
I spoke captain fantastic and I've seen
many things come through my walls is
Britney Spears a meth head is the
question alright we've answered early on
Sam look t her former manager this is a
guy who was sued by Britney and her
parents claiming that he hooked her on
drugs while he was managing her he is
claiming that he was quite the opposite
trying to keep her off of drugs in fact
he claims that at one time he brought
drug sniffing dogs into her house and he
claims the dogs found a stash of crystal
meth in her home he's
says the woman with no dough one their
own method
I'm just the cashier once they found the
drugs he says the meth was taken away
and by taking away I mean so he is
saying he's going to sue Brittany and
her parents for saying he's a drug an
enabler when in reality he was a drug
Savior well it would explain the shaving
her head an umbrella incident I mean I
buy that she's on mass he was there he's
neighbor from the meth you know who
could use some meth porn star kim
kardashian she could use some meth uh I
don't know we've changed it happened
with [ __ ] tapes Kim Kardashian
I told you last week that her boyfriend
Kanye West is telling her to lose 20
pounds yes
so that she can be the face of his new
fashion line well this week she talked
about the fact that she has to lose some
weight she tweeted that she's unhappy
that her sister Kourtney and her have
the same amount of weight to lose and
Kourtney just had a baby here's the
thing this whole time I was expecting
some sort of commercial angle to this
whole story they're following tweek to
him right after that one saying since I
started using QuickTrim again I'm down
six pounds and feeling better there's no
way she was just being candid and narrow
rationale she was selling it's funny
look it's quick trim there's a five
million dollar lawsuit against the
Kardashians from people have used quick
trim and it didn't work for them and
it's also been found to be unsafe by the
FDA
I think meth would be a better way to
lose weight for her than QuickTrim would
be you can find anything this is what
bums me out about that whole [ __ ]
thing I now know more about her than I
know about some people that I'm blood
relatives with Hulk Hogan had a sex tape
that got leaked this week making starts
to important star Hulk Hogan maybe we
can use it here you know it brother
Gawker composted a minute of the 30
minute tape this week it features the 59
year old wrestler and a woman who
apparently in the video is the wife of
his best friend no DJ Bubba the Love
Sponge what really was a character from
Sponge Bob Squarepants he's good he's
best friends with Hulk Hogan Hulk is
banging his wife Heather Clem in this
video but every time the video is made
shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
correcting my ass oh I want Claire it
had her be [ __ ] right if you're gonna
correct me but you're saying they were
divorced they're divorced now is were
they cheating no here's that gets even
better at the time the video was made
yeah they were still married because you
can hear Bob of the Love Sponge
off-camera saying to them okay you to do
your thing have a good time I'll be in
the office if you need me
they're swinging yeah oh my god man this
gets juicy I got a little hard this is
exciting so he leaves the room and then
Hulk gives her the suplex here it comes
sister and for about 30 minutes they go
at it and then he says I'm gonna go say
goodbye to him the Bubba in the other
room and holy [ __ ] now now I would pay
any price to see that now not any price
I'd pay like 19 that's real money it's
being shopped around but of course
Hulkster has a lawsuit trying to cease
and decision why man he's 59 what the
[ __ ] let it be out there man Kim
Kardashian has an entire career off of a
[ __ ] tape yeah why not the sad part is
towards the end of the Tabas are talking
about how bloated he feels cuz he had a
lot of sushi that's his pillow talk so
she's like [ __ ] me Hulk he's like I had
a little too much Blowfish
eat too much sushi tonight I know he's
refering to her or whether he actually
had raw fish in a related story Linda
Hogan his ex-wife got pulled over in a
DUI the day after the tape was released
she was pulled over in Malibu with a
blood alcohol level of point zero eight
four which is just over the legal limit
anyway she said she was not drinking
because the tape came out she's not
upset by it she would simply had a glass
of champagne or an empty stomach and
that's why she blew over the legal limit
I bet she is she's celebrating cuz she
saw the tape said I don't have to [ __ ]
that guy anymore with that horrible man
tan and the the weird blonde hair the
ring of hair around his head and he was
always burping sushi on me that's more
reality show news from the set of
American Idol apparently the new judges
are at each other's throats Nicki Minaj
and Mariah Carey had a very public feud
someone captured it on a cell phone
video and released it this week it
basically is more Nicki Minaj
threatening to knock Mariah Carey out
than saying I told them I'm not [ __ ]
putting up with her [ __ ] Highness
over there Mariah Carey blabbed a
Barbara Walters the next day the more
than one person overheard Nicky sang on
the set if I had a gun I would shoot the
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's one way fox can
get me to watch American Idol this year
start arming Nicki Minaj and Mariah
Carey start slow build up two Suites
given like numchucks to begin with then
throwing stars then maybe a switchblade
a bike chain
I mean build up can we start with foxy
boxing know what a weapon of some kind
and then we go to firearms and we go to
like a small handgun and then a
semi-automatic like a salt rifle and
then zookas and hand grenades I've seen
the video it's pretty funny man it's
funny when you see famous people react
to one another in a way that you're not
a customer saying and who do you feel
worse for in that situation yes I think
we all win if they're fighting except
for Keith Urban he was sitting in the
car like oh my god it's bad enough I got
a [ __ ] Nicole Kidman now I gotta listen
to these two are you watching breaking
Amish the reality show breaking Amish no
well there's a Mennonite now who's very
happy breaking Amish is a show on TLC
which really hasn't just become the
sideshow Channel now there's people with
two [ __ ] heads conjoined and there's
boo boo [ __ ] and there's all kinds of
[ __ ] up people on Till's
wasn't this fun breaking Amish is about
four or five Amish people who go on the
room spring up if we with room spring up
is when you're allowed in the Amish
community at a certain age you enter
your late teens or early 20s or
something
and you're encouraged to leave the
community go out for two years go
amongst the English just like in witness
yeah and and you're allowed to sow your
oats yeah there say you can go and you
can go live in man's world Mount Lee and
you could go do whatever you want for a
while and at the end of rums fritter or
whatever of two years you decide whether
or not you want
come back to the community you do you
leave all that [ __ ] behind if you yes
just churning butter and [ __ ] hats
beards Barnes that's they are speculate
about how much of this show is real
there been some rumors that maybe
they're setting some of this up just for
television I'll tell you one thing for
certain on the show Rebecca 20 year old
Rebecca and one of the Amish girls has
no [ __ ] teeth don't know why Kevin no
no no because apparently and you find
out when you watch television so much
interesting stuff the Amish life is
shaped you down and pull all the [ __ ]
teeth out of your head yeah that's what
I said maybe Rebecca can explain it
better it's very common for yeah wait
yeah they're not all nice just buggy
driving [ __ ] butter churners my
friend no evil [ __ ] goes down there well
how do they eat dentures ill-fitting
dentures
she had blisters and her gums from
ill-fitting dentures so she went to a
dentist in the in the real world here
where we live in the 21st [ __ ]
century with sonic Karen [ __ ] so you
don't have to pull your teeth out and
this woman felt so bad first she gave
her a set of proper fitting dentures so
now she can chew her food it's so
harrowing but the good news is we know
we could start dating Amish chicks man
ABC isn't a reality show in the works
called celebrity splash it'll be
celebrities performing various dives
from diving boards oh I got a shot dude
I could do a mean cannonball
you better get your agent on it only if
I can wear a shirt though I ain't going
[ __ ] bare-chested
not unless they pay up man if they want
to see these guns they got to [ __ ]
put some coinage on the table speed holy
[ __ ] if they were like look we'll make
it a serious offer a million bucks you
got to do the dive in a speedo nothing
else I would [ __ ] totally do it
would you really oh my god I'd do it
here's what would happen I'd watch it
everyone between this fat piece of [ __ ]
they'd be watching my flab but on the
way down
right just slowing me down making me
less aerodynamic I'd get out of the pool
they'd hand me a briefcase full of
[ __ ] money and [ __ ] and then it would
make me go on a diet cuz the whole world
be like you fat piece of [ __ ] I'd be
like I got enough money to get thin
goodbye everybody
and then it's the two fat - dive tour
for ya for the next year and a half two
celebrities will perform a series of
complicated dives from varying heights
including the 10 meter high board and
then they have to do backflips
somersaults and other gymnastic feats in
the dives ABCs gone about it so weakly I
don't want to watch celebrities [ __ ]
diving I want to watch like celebrity
rectal you know what I'm saying they
don't have to show me detail man just to
just go to the office with celebrities
and tape their reactions and how they
talk to the doctor like the nervous
banter of just like huh sorry I had
beams last night I want to see Will
Smith uncomfortably [ __ ] smirk his
way through a rectal exam and then I
want to see like they focus on him and
then like when the doctors done you he
steps back you know you're here to slap
it a glove and then they rack focus to
him and he's just like you're all good
in there you know just like gives him
his [ __ ] diagnosis or whatever or mr.
Smith I'm sorry I found a small [ __ ]
car and they're you know whatever just
that's a show that I would totally
[ __ ] watch it I know a lot of people
be like what trash TV but that'd be
[ __ ] fascinating man watch it people
dive come on I don't I want to see
Kirstie Alley break her neck from the
10-meter board I think that's really
yeah that's the other thing people get
hurt only if they do the show live I
would encourage him to do it live I
would do that way cuz people would tune
in going
but [ __ ] somebody gets hurt and like
car racing you want to see the disaster
how might people watch car racing
there's no other [ __ ] reason to watch
cause we've seen car racing they go in a
circle
through four hours it's like being stuck
behind a Korean in a parking lot
I'm kidding the agents are excellent
drivers honey Boo Boo's getting death
threats she's a [ __ ] kid Alana
Thompson has apparently been getting
death threats now apparently June the
400-pound 33 year old grandmother says
she won't let her daughter go anywhere
without their constant supervision
listen if you want you don't have to
kill this family have you watched the
show just wait wait like a month have
you seen how they live they're not gonna
be here long anyway it's fine there
ought to be clutching their chest and
Keeling over in about a month
you better [ __ ] redneck ik nice man
Robert Pattinson is the sexiest man in
the world
according to Glamour magazine the women
who read Glamour answered a poll and
they [ __ ] that indeed I was Kristen
Stewart by the way fourth year in a row
he is the sexiest man alive I would
definitely vote him as Wis pious man
alive
he's definitely got wispy down to a
science but I don't know if I would say
flimsy flimsy perhaps you think so yeah
but not too sexy he gave it to him
because he's the everyone's all [ __ ]
sad for him because he got cheated on
everybody knows Alexander Skarsgard a
14th on the list 14 I've seen that dude
[ __ ] naked on that TV show he should
be number one number two she's not that
it's big it's just [ __ ] luscious Tom
Hardy's 20th on the list well perhaps
he's wondering why you would put the man
number one who's wispy in movie news
November the 9th Skyfall the latest
James Bond movie will be released
November celebrates the 50th anniversary
of James Bond in the movies and it has
been confirmed by Daniel Craig himself
this week that it's true bond will not
be drinking martinis shaken nor stirred
nor otherwise this time around he's
drinking Heineken beer in the movie
instead of martinis good the [ __ ] here
fine you can apparently step up and made
a major cash deposit into the producers
coffers and they have bought all the
alcohol rights in the film so bond
drinks Heinekens now can they shake it
not stir it at least take it up it's
right why we're talking about James Bond
the theme Skyfall Adele's new theme for
the movie came out this week it came out
at just after midnight in London 7
minutes after midnight 0 0 7 a.m. here's
a little taste of Adele singing Skyfall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what the movie opening is gonna
be for movies I can't wait to see two
movies that will suck Warner Brothers
announced Yogi Bear 2 this week it was
successful enough to go a second round
made over 200 million dollars worldwide
you may remember Dan Aykroyd is the
voice of Yogi Bear and the rebooted
franchise you remember who played boo
boo just invest in Tim just simple like
I said Justin Bieber Justin Timberlake
in Timberlake yeah no word on whether
this will be a sequel or they say maybe
a prequel with a young teenaged yogi and
a baby boo boo could they make it
[ __ ] worse
I already shat myself when I heard the
plans know we're gonna do or make him
younger and hipper it's like it's like
yogi wears a baseball cap turn to the
side and wears a lot of bling and says
yo yo yo Ranger Smith [ __ ] you they're
gonna totally poochy it man Hasbro has
announced their movie plans this week as
well [ __ ] kill me now these are the
people brought you battleship you
remember battleship don't you based on
the board game by Hasbro action man will
be the first of a new film they're gonna
make this is the British version of GI
Joe the doll yeah instead of the GI Joe
in England they call him action man
because they don't have any [ __ ] GIS
in England cuz it's [ __ ] England I
mean is it that beloved a name or a
franchise like oh [ __ ] the entire action
man audience is gonna come out yes all
the people love action like my
grandfather is on his way man because he
loved action man 1ru action man that's
right I am action man what do you do
action man monopoly the movie looking
forward to that
is he gonna start the little dude in the
Hat it's got her right what possible
difference could it make one way or the
other I'll be honest with you I've
always been curious about his story
how'd he get so rich how is he so wise
did he meet boo-boo when he was a baby I
want it I'm making fun of this but I
have an audition next week for Community
Chest so yeah and lastly and I used to
make this [ __ ] joke in fact we made
it on a podcast many many moons ago I
think Hungry Hungry Hippos the movie
will be coming to a major a major
Cineplex near you I hope to land a lead
role in that picture
I'm lip Oh on the plane
apparently Khloe Kardashian already has
one of the she'll be playing the purple
hippo Miley Cyrus is in talks to star in
a remake of Bonnie and Clyde for
television for television History
Channel had a lot of success with the
Hatfields and McCoys huge success they
are going to do a a reboot of the Bonnie
and Clyde legend and they want her to
play Bonnie who would play they're
trying to get her real-life boyfriend
Liam Hemsworth from Hunger Games to play
him I would watch because there's a
happy ending because it means she gets
riddled with bullets from a Thompson
submachine gun at some point I would be
sitting there with my popcorn just good
boob just my little DVR ten seconds back
I saw her at a premiere once man she
seems very in control of her faculties
she's I mean as much as like we give her
[ __ ] on the show she seemed okay to me
gotta be careful of her giant teeth
though that's the only thing if you're
ever in person you have to feed her
sugar cube with your hand flat don't get
your fingers near your mouth she will
take your [ __ ] finger off she doesn't
mean to she's just hungry I don't blame
her for it but you just have to be
careful fronts are pretty big oh man she
got sick I saw [ __ ] Sully and Mike
stealing two of them to get back to boom
that's a monster thing sure is that's
for the kids in the audience there's a
few people with kids who are just like I
just watched that very exciting music
news John Travolta an Olivia newton-john
are reuniting
they're doing a Christmas album called
this Christmas this is recent this is
coming out next month I saw a photo for
this I don't know when it happened I
thought it was old but holy [ __ ] it
looks [ __ ] creepy man yes they both
are like just pulled yeah yeah they
reunite for the first time since Greece
really you know for a project not true
they did that movie twister was twisted
I think it was really it was like they
got put together by angels one of them
died Yeah right back together again
since that [ __ ] you I was just busting
to jam man but it was twist of fate the
album the whole bunch of duets on it
including one written by the guy who
wrote you're the one that I want from
Greece Oh get out of here
it's called I think you might like it
which oddly enough is also a John
Travolta said to a guy who was given a
massage
other songs John Travolta will sing on
the album I'll be home over Christmas
mommy saw me kissing Santa Claus and
sleigh ride my ass till I beg you to
stop
Kevin and I are big geeks that's why
every week we take a look at the geek
news
[Music]
our best wishes go out to legend Stanley
this week the Marvel comic book legend
had heart surgery in Los Angeles 90
years old Stanley is yeah he ended it as
a solid he came out and did an episode
of comic book men that show that we do
on AMC which I saw some footage on and
he was so good there's one shot of the
in the show where he's sitting on the
counter and the four boys are just
sitting on the floor at his feet he's
telling him stories rather adorable
middle-aged men are just sitting at the
foot of foot of this [ __ ] ancient old
man but what a [ __ ] trouper man 90
[ __ ] years old he had a pacemaker put
in apparently and he released the
following statement in an effort to be
more like my fellow Avenger - bender
Tony Stark
I had an electronic pacemaker placed
near my heart to ensure I'll be able to
lead thee for another 90 years that's a
good guy I haven't seen him since the
operation but he's a [ __ ] loser if
he'd haven't put it on the outside with
some blight connected to it you know
what I mean
totally so awesome it's a missed
opportunity now a big round glowing
[ __ ] pacemaker on his chest that's
what he should have [ __ ] 90 to go
into surgery and put a bass brave to be
honest with you
well Excelsior excelsior I thought you
said let's so um I'm like he's why what
the [ __ ] and Mark Wayne Williams of
Petoskey Michigan's in the news again
this week we've talked about Mark Wayne
Williams before he is the real-life
Batman of matowski Michigan I guess it
was a Batman for everywhere including
Petoskey Michigan
he was found lurking on the rooftops in
a Batman costume carrying chemical spray
and a baton a few months ago the police
captured him and said don't [ __ ] do
that why can't they just let him be me
because he had sand-filled gloves to use
ASAPS he had a metal baton and chemical
spray for people's eyes he was prepared
for a [ __ ] war on crime Ralph
they brought him in gave him a six
months probation and said do not dress
up like the
anymore douchebag well this week mark
Wayne Williams couldn't resist the call
and put the cape and cowl back on again
had he been retired for eight [ __ ]
years at that point no just six months
which ottoman already makes him a better
Batman than Christian Bale in Dark
Knight at least this guy still [ __ ]
trying he went to the scene of a an
accident where the other driver had sped
off it was a hit-and-run so he shows up
in his Batman costume and said he wanted
to help find the driver who ran off and
the cops are like we got this covered
Batman thank you and they said please
leave and he wouldn't leave the scene of
the crime he kept insisting that he was
going to find the criminal and they had
canines there to get the scent of the
car and he was screwing up with the
scent apparently smelled poorly and was
making the dogs crazy so they had to
haul him in and they arrested him again
gave him another 6 months probation and
told him to stop dressing like a weirdo
this dude doesn't quite understand
Batman if he allowed himself to be
arrested by common police he should have
hit the grappling gun the [ __ ] path
and he could have [ __ ] took where was
the swarm of bats that's supposed to
come when he hits that a garage door
opener and then they all show up it's
the problem man when you meet the real
life Batman sometimes they just don't
[ __ ] match up and I bet Michael
Keaton once man was at the Dogma
premiere and [ __ ] and I was hoping for
Batman but instead he left the movie
twenty minutes in to make phone calls in
the lobby and I was like that's not very
Batman it is if the Joker's on the loose
your son who I hadn't thought of that
[ __ ] important to break in Arkham and
then you wanted to sit through the whole
movie why didn't he think of that man
cuz I walked out a lobby I'd seen the
movie a bunch I walked out and I see him
there and he looks at I mean he looks
caught and he goes like this great movie
and then goes back to his conversation
but what he should have just done was
been like the Riddler's loose no holy
[ __ ] Batman
hey taking twos and theaters this
weekend did you guys see taken - anybody
seen taken - what the [ __ ]
people have no pulse if you don't see
taken to his daughter got taken in the
first one and now someone else gets
taken in this one the trailer was
[ __ ] gripping man when he was just
like listen you're gonna be taken again
listen remember how you were taken
before
well they shits going down again I've
got a very special schedule skills or
set of skills I can't wait to see
[ __ ] three man cuz three is gonna be
like listen to me closely I'm gonna be
taking out the garbage I'll be right
back Liam's doing a ton of promotion for
it this week everyone everywhere man go
now I'm DeGeneres I half-expected he was
gonna be on our show he was he was on
ESPN he was on the Bravo network there's
a talk-show there with a guy named Andy
Cohen called watch what happens it's
called he was on there with Ethan Hawke
whose goals are promoting a movie called
sinister and so they were talking about
stuff and Andy Cohen foes you don't know
is the openly gay
very funny talk-show host he does that
roundtable with the Real Housewives and
stuff but I was watching all the
coverage this week all the interviews
really not one person said don't you
have a big [ __ ] no one said that to him
except the gay guy on Bravo really Andy
Cohen had the sack to ask him about his
giant [ __ ] and here's what he had to say
rumor has it that you are unequivocably
the most well-endowed person in
Hollywood well I'm told Willem Dafoe and
myself are kind of very good
[Applause]
ethan hawke says that the correct term
is head to head actually should be going
head to head no the correct term I've
had to head is docking yeah yeah so he
says hey man Willem Dafoe he's legendary
yeah really
his green goblin is monstrous so that's
him kind of copping to it like yeah it's
[ __ ] huge yeah go see taken to I've
got a massive [ __ ] my massive [ __ ] is
going to be taken which leads us to a
musical question we ask each and every
week here at Hollywood babble-on
[Music]
I don't the wire I can Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is the stuff of legend and for many
many episodes in a row now we've been
taking your facts about Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] this is the 100th episode
anniversary edition of how big is Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it takes two movies to be taken Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big his condoms have
mile markers Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it wasn't even in the room and it'd
still be President Obama and Mitt Romney
in the debate Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big
[Applause]
trees hide behind it to take a pee tell
that joke to your mom Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big to see the base you have to go
back in time lupard intriguing Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big amanda bynes has
locked herself inside of it and is
refusing to answer anyone Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it's what Optimus Prime
is hauling in his trailer
ladies his [ __ ] is so big one morning he
woke up with a hippie chain to it you
know those environmental fees
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he doesn't
do it doggystyle he does it Gangnam
style
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that 100 episodes in we've only been
describing the tip
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen a Reno Nevada if
you had a good time this evening thank
you so much for sharing our 100th
episode with us it's great to have you
guys here thank you for being here for
for the biggest show of the of our runs
of our means a lot man we've made it
this far and we do it because you guys
listen every weekend and you're here at
live shows means the world to me to hang
out with him and make some [ __ ] jokes
this is my favorite live show to do man
so I appreciate you guys being on here I
[Applause]
want to say thank you to Kevin for
making all this possible we kind of
built this on the back of SModcast and
then this Monaco Network and and being
part of this has been one of the great
experiences of my life so thanks to
Kevin and all of his followers who have
embraced me so kindly over the past
hundred episodes
that's enough [ __ ] e for the yes
we love us lazy imma go out sweat and
[ __ ] spend some money win some
[ __ ] money as we say in Reena welcome
to Reno put a dick in your mouth that's
that's it for Hollywood babble-on 100
men I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
babble the [ __ ] off cannot Reno Thank
You Reno
[Applause]
[Music]
you